Wake up Senpai Senpai wake up. Oh, you're still a bit dizzy. That's okay. I hit you on the head
pretty hard. Up in Adam though, I heard you wanted to get to know me better. So I brought my special
love diary with all the information about me that you need to know so we can be together forever.
And I'll have all the time in the world to get to know you too! So let's get started!
My name is Mercy Modiste. Mercy being the last thing people say before they're killed.
And Modiste meaning dressmaker in French. My birthday is March 15th. In Japanese that's
Saikou. Saikou means the best. Oh, sorry. Don't worry about that. That's not my blood.
Oh, where was I? I am an ex-student and my height is 160 centimeters tall. Meaning I'm about
five three in freedom units. Here are my likes Senpai. I love you Senpai! I love you so much.
I also really love ear snacks, children's cartoon, color coordination. So if we everywhere
matching outfits together. Artbooks, they make me so happy. And I love phrase, especially from you
Senpai! I love phrase. As my dislikes, I dislike eggs. All kinds of eggs. I'm allergic. I dislike
porridge. It reminds me of when I'm sick. Beer. I don't like beer, but I do like beer snacks. So
I like the saltiness of beer snacks but not beer. I dislike coffee. The bad fridge. Coffee flavor
things are okay though. My uvula is kind of enlargent. So it makes my throat kind of irritated.
So I don't like carbonation. I don't like math and numbers. Memorizing your phone number Senpai
is so hard. And where you live, it's really hard to memorize all that. It's okay if you don't know
these. But if you do know these, you are based and super lit. I'm kind of pretentious and I kind
of have like pretentious likes. So some notable ones here for animes I like are Cardcaptor Sakura,
Hunter Hunter, Dungeon Meshie, Death Note, Cowboy Beepop. I think you understand my tastes.
As for games I like as well, I love story-based games. As you can see though, I really need to
expand my gaming repertoire. So please help me Senpai. As for movies I like, I believe these are
the best of the best. The greasy strangler, eagle eye, gold swatch. It's such a beautiful day.
Sherlock Jr. Imitation of Life. Bro, peeping Tom. I can't wait to share them with you Senpai. I hope
we can do like Watch Alongs of my favorites. As for music, I kind of don't listen to music Senpai.
So all I really listen to are like classical music, game, OSTs, songs my friends made and recommend
to me. But yeah, I like working in silence. Here are the credits. All the credits will also be on
the Violaur website. So I'd like to give special thanks to Design, Squishy Ghoul, and The Rig,
Dean Nari. Thank you so much everyone on this page for allowing me to meet Senpai.
Alright, skill times. I am super perceptive. So if something's wrong, I will know right away. I'm
like a little secret detective. I can speak basic Vietnamese.
Stop.
Come on, Neil. And I know only like really baby Japanese.
I have decent acting and decent singing skills as well. A variety of interesting
laughs and noises. And I'm a super ganky girl. My hobbies are snooping, photography, research,
media study, being a total weeb, fashion design, and what's this down here? Oh, who put that there?
My weakness is motion sickness. That is why most of my games are like that. I mean, sorry,
that's the third thing in the way. Overthinking. I tend to overthink a lot. If things are too simple,
I might overthink them and just go like, no, it can't be that simple. And of course, in patients,
I'm a little impatient with a lot of things. Okay, here are my goals, Senpai. So my goals are
to pursue voice acting and appear in an anime or video game, move to a place with better internet,
get a sound isolation booth, get over my motion sickness to play first person games,
host a concert and perform 3D lives or events or even 3D skits, to bring to life my original songs
that I wrote, to have a product based off of me, to bring home a play button for my mother who's
always wanted to see one, to reach over a million Senpais and make them smile, and to make memories
with you, my darling Senpai. And of course, the best one of all, to reach my perfect very tail
happily ever after. And I won't let anyone get in that way. Here are my tags, Senpai. I have no
idea. I'm not very creative. I'm not very punny. In 2.0, I'm going to ask my Senpais for a bit of
help with my tags. My Oshi mark is a pair of scissors, broken the heart, but I don't want my
heart broken. So you guys will fix that up, right? And the fan name for these little guys
are called snippets. Aren't they super, super adorable guy? Let's talk about my favorite thing,
my gen mates. These are drawn in the style of sechis like blue archive work. So they're super,
super funny and cute. My first impressions of my gen mates is that in me is surprisingly
hick, but in a cute way, baby girl. She's a super memer. I see when I first saw her,
I thought she would be super mesugecky. And guess what? I was right. Mumme, sometimes I'm scared
of her. Not gonna lie, but I feel very loved. She's very clumsy, but in a like a super cute way.
Shivi is so brave, very independent, cool, independent woman. She's a hard worker. Maybe
she works too hard. Azura right here. I thought she was a dancer when I first saw her because
of her colors. She is mommy. Like that's it. She's mommy. That's it. Her voice is very good. I
have never heard a voice so dripping and like lost. I'm just a great gamer and a legatic.
I love them so much. Let me show me off to you guys now to my senpai's. Look at my feetsies
with my knee high fishnet socks as well. You can't see that part. Sorry. I have wonderful
garters on me. I'm sorry about the band-aids. I'm just really clumsy guys. My beautiful bouncy bow.
And of course my choker. Let's have a closer look, huh? Here's some of my expressions that I can do.
It can look like this weird little freaking hamster. I can be really angry if you guys piss me off.
Suddenly there seems to be no more senpai's. And I can cry. You don't want to make me sad,
right senpai? I also have a dark face. So if I'm very disappointed in you, I also have dead fish eyes.
Blush in case I love you so much senpai. Heart eyes, which I always am in love with you senpai.
Question mark. Oh, sorry. It's a little bit up. What did you mean by that? What happened? I don't
get it. My shock dies. Senpai, you love me, right? You love me, right? I can smile a little bit.
And of course my famous yandere hands. I love you so much senpai. And you may ask,
what's under my eye patch? It's another eye. I wear this eye patch so I can see in the dark
so I can always see you no matter what senpai. Now that that's sort of over. I want you guys
to like and subscribe. Leave a comment, of course. But as always, our times are going to be cut short.
So take a deep breath now. Really deeply now. I'll see you soon.